euh j'ouvre notre second thème consacré
à ce jour de crise sans fin dans lequel
c'est ton français le système de santé
français l'expression elle est signée
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était le 6 janvier
dernier le jour le chef de l'État a
annoncé son plan de sauvetage
recrutement d'infirmières d'assistant
médicaux meilleurs rémunération des
heures de nuit la fin de la tarification
à l'activité la mise en place d'un
tandem médecin et puis administratif à
la tête des des hôpitaux avant
d'entendre nos experts on voit comment
réagissent les soignants de l'hôpital de
Beaune avec ce reportage de Yann et fêlé
le président de la République à
Corbeil-Essonnes devant les
professionnels de santé pour présenter
ses vœux et des pistes de réformes ces
soignants de beaux ont écouté le
discours et nous livre leur réaction
premier sujet abordé par le président le
temps de travail à l'hôpital c'est le
dernier endroit où juridiquement les 35
heures fonctionnent encore c'est une
hyper rigidité moi sur le service des
urgences effectivement les 35 heures
sont presqu'un leur les agents
travaillent plus si on met ça dans des
balances horaires
au final on sait pas trop ce qu'on va en
faire on va essayer de le rendre dans la
mesure du possible 35 heures ou 39
heures ce qu'il faut c'est garantir à
nos soignants qu'ils auront leur repos
et qu'ils pourront justement avoir
garantir aussi leur vie personnelle quoi
je pense que aujourd'hui on est face à
une jeune génération qui a des exigences
et qui a raison et qui ne fera peut-être
pas les sacrifices que nous nous avons
fait qu'ils ont fait des heures
supplémentaires largement rémunérés et
et défiscalisé déjà ça a une certaine
forme d'attractivité mais ça a eu ça a
eu une fin aussi c'est-à-dire que là à
l'été c'était beaucoup plus compliqué et
malgré malgré les conditions favorables
de trouver des soignants quand même pour
revenir c'est à dire que oui c'est bien
mais ça délimite on les a atteintes
alors le chef de l'État veut dégager
davantage de temps de soins pour les
professionnels une idée particulièrement
chère au soignants qui témoignent
souvent d'une perte de sens dans leur
action l'outil informatique demande
aussi beaucoup de temps et les soignants
ont l'impression d'être empêchés parce
qu'ils ont l'impression de bâcler leurs
soins et de faire des soins à la chaîne
mais en même temps la T2A nous oblige
également à la traçabilité à valoriser
les séjours et donc il faut bien qu'on
mette ce que nous avons fait
effectivement mais du coup c'est tout du
temps qui n'est pas passé au lit du
patient toutes les spécialités manquent
de personnel mais certaines font face à
des problématiques supplémentaires
exemple en gériatrie les personnages qui
rentrent en institution aujourd'hui
sont des personnes âgées qui sont de
plus en plus dépendantes et donc avec
une charge en soins quand même de plus
en plus importante c'est vrai que ce qui
n'est pas suffisamment pris en compte
c'est l'évolution populationnelle et ça
monsieur Macron a parlé également d'être
plus près des besoins de la population
et ça ça pèse aussi sur les soignants
autre aspect pesant sur lequel en temps
revenir Emmanuel Macron la tarification
à l'activité c'est la principale
ressource des hôpitaux un financement
dépendant de la nature et de la quantité
des actes médicaux réalisés le Président
ouvre une concertation le directeur de
Beaune a une proposition peut-être la
responsabilité populationnelle Beaune
c'est 100000 habitants et bien que coûte
la santé pour 100000 habitants si on
arrive à l'estimer et je suis et qu'on
nous apporte cette ressource à nous
après en responsabilité de l'utiliser et
au meilleur avec la meilleure efficacité
possible ou service de la population et
qu'on soit évalué là-dessus Emmanuel
Macron veut aller vite le nouveau
système devrait être fils les pour le
prochain de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
ce plan annoncé par Emmanuel Macron
est-il suffisamment ambitieux quels sont
les mesures les plus efficaces en en
débat avec Bernard jaumier bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes médecin généraliste
sénateur écologiste à part un TPS de
Paris et vice-président de la commission
des affaires sociales Olivia treignault
bonsoir présidente de l'intersyndical
national des internes j'accueil Frédéric
Valtou bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
députés horizon de la Seine-et-Marne
l'ancien président de la Fédération
hospitalière de France avec nous
également en duplex en visioconférence
de niturio le maire renaissance de
Nevers bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation Émilie
zappalski évidemment est resté à mes
côtés Bernard jaumier question assez
générale pour commencer ensuite on
rentrera dans le détail des des mesures
annoncées on va c'est tellement vaste la
santé on va essayer de se focaliser
quand même un peu plus sur le sur
l'hôpital et l'hôpital public ce plan
santé d'Emmanuel Macron et si vous
semble à la hauteur de cette crise il
dit un jour de crise sans fin de notre
système de santé alors dans ces paroles
il est intéressant et j'aurais du veut
pas dire le contraire puisque j'ai été à
l'Élysée quand il a présenté ma santé
2022 et que les 10 chantiers de ma santé
2022 on les retrouve dans les annonces
du chef de l'État santé 2022 c'était il
y a et c'était 2017-2018 donc c'était il
y a 5 6 ans donc notamment vous venez de
parler de la T2A enfin cette
tarification ce truc technocratique
dans ma santé 2022 donc 5 ou 6 ans plus
tard les mêmes propositions
malheureusement elles sont toujours
d'actualité régie malheureusement parce
que en creux ça signifie que pas grand
chose a été fait alors certes il y a eu
la crise covid mais ça n'explique pas
tout donc il y a des choses qui sont
tout à fait intéressantes dans ce qu'a
dit le chef de l'État et il y a une
nouveauté c'est que pour la première
fois il a parlé de la nécessité
d'adopter des objectifs de santé en
amont de la décision d'allocation de
moyens c'est avant de dire où on met
l'argent et de voter le budget de la
Sécurité sociale d'avoir une discussion
sur les objectifs de santé alors moi je
défends complètement dans cette
nécessité qu'on est un débat dans les
territoires et au Parlement quelques
mois avant qu'on vote le budget de la
Sécurité sociale pour dire quelles sont
nos objectifs de santé est-ce que ça
veut dire que le patients les malades
vous semblent au cœur de du dispositif
ou de ou du plan de annoncé par le chef
de l'État j'ai pas beaucoup entendu ces
mots là en tout cas pendant le discours
et donc est-ce qu'ils sont au cœur quand
on en parle pas le plus que ça je suis
pas sûr on en a toujours pas parlé dans
les questions de gouvernance alors que
peut-être ils disent toutes leurs places
et on a l'impression qu'on déplaçant que
la question se pose toujours pas sur
quelle va être la population demain quel
besoin de santé elle a et comment on
fait pour répondre à ces à ses objectifs
là j'ai l'impression toujours le
problème à l'envers et qu'on répond
toujours à une urgence après l'autre
sauf qu'au bout d'un moment ça marche
pas et il faut et d'ailleurs il le dit
très bien dans son discours le président
Emmanuel Macron il faut arrêter et
sortir du court terme voir à plus moyen
long terme cette fois peut-être avec des
objectifs qui aboutissent à quelque
chose et non pas encore un nouveau
discours similaire dans cinq ans donc là
il y a un cap Frédéric va tout parce que
c'est ça qui est intéressant
effectivement on peut dire pourquoi ça
n'a pas été fait lors du premier
quinquennat il y a eu quand même bon il
y a eu la crise covid il y a eu quand
même le Ségur de la santé je vais
rappeler quelques chiffres 12 milliards
d'euros annuels pour mieux rémunérer les
soignants 19 milliards pour investir
dans les hôpitaux
ça a pas suffi pourquoi c'est pourquoi
c'est insuffisant pourquoi c'était
insuffisant alors il y a deux choses je
pense que il y a quand même la crise
covid c'est pas marginale ça pendant
deux trois ans on a fichu la paix aux
hospitalises et autres choses à faire on
doit générer une formation et on a
financièrement assuré l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire le bon fonctionnement de
l'ensemble tout en sachant effectivement
que il y avait il y avait des problèmes
ce qui est intéressant dans le discours
de d'Emmanuel Macron c'est effectivement
la vision globale la vision long terme
et surtout qui ne regarde pas que
l'hôpital mais qui regarde l'ensemble du
système de santé et qui finalement
déroule le programme d'un quinquennat
puisque on le sait bien
tout ne sera pas fait dans un projet loi
tu ne seras pas fait dans une loi de
financement la sécurité sociale et il y
a des choses qui vont à des chantiers
qui vont être plus ou moins faciles et
rapides à mettre à mettre en oeuvre et
puis d'autres qui vont prendre plusieurs
années donc mais au moins on a une
vision globale c'est ce qu'il fallait je
pense après le covid et en début de
quinquennat maintenant il faut
effectivement que ça soit pas juste un
beau discours qui reste à l'état de
discours et si en 2018 on n'a pas été
plus loin lui-même l'a dit il a dit il a
reconnu que
ce qu'il avait dit déjà en septembre
2018 puisque ça date là qu'il avait fait
ce discours et bien il avait sans doute
manquer de vigilance sur ou de
volontarisme sur la mise en oeuvre qui a
des choses qui n'avaient pas avancé
aussi rapidement qu'elles auraient pu
oui je trouve que c'est une façon assez
prudente de le dire enfin c'est gentil
de le dire parce que on a vu quand même
évidemment qu'il y a eu la crise covid
mais on les diagnostics les états des
lieux quand même sur la situation de la
santé qu'elle soit publique ou privée on
la connaît on les connaît c'est pas une
découverte ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'année dernière encore on sur une
mission flash qui avait lancé François
Braun pour les urgences comme enfin ça
donnait l'impression qu'on gagnait du
temps en fait avant de passer à l'action
et c'est vrai qu'en termes de
communication même si on a cette vision
long terme en effet qui est bonne ces
mots qu'on entend on n'a pas encore
l'impression qu'il y a les actes qui
suivent et peut-être que ça sera en deux
temps mais ça fait beaucoup de
piétinement on a l'impression avec juste
pour terminer un François Brune un
ministre quand même de la santé qui est
assez peu présent c'est Emmanuel Macron
qui est aux manettes comme beaucoup de
sujets sur le sur actuellement mais du
coup sa personnalise un peu moins cette
réforme
et ensuite je vais chercher je vais
donner à part au maire de la crise a eu
entre autres vertus de montrer à tous
les professionnels qui pouvaient
travailler ensemble et sans doute
impulsé sur le terrain des habitudes de
travail que que qui ont accéléré un
certain nombre voilà qu'on déclenché un
certain nombre effectivement de qu'on
révélé la possibilité la nécessité de
décloisonner je pense tout ça c'est ça
qui est important et puis le fait que ce
soit le président de la République qui
porte ça pour moi c'est une réforme
majeure le système de santé donc à la
rigueur c'est au contraire lui donner un
cap encore plus fort les objectifs sont
posés par le Président de la République
c'est une urgence nationale le système
de santé et il le met quasiment au-delà
de la pile des réformes à venir Denis
turio je repose presque la question sur
du du Ségur vous qui êtes évidemment en
tant que mère de Nevers en contact
direct avec les soignants la direction
de de l'hôpital de la ville pourquoi
l'argent qui a été débloqué qui a quand
même été massif lors du Ségur pourquoi
ça ne suffit pas on est toujours dans ce
dans cette difficulté cette quête de
sens c'est soignants qui se disent ou se
sentent maltraitants pourquoi ça n'a pas
suffi après vous
oui quête de sens c'est aussi quête de
considération quand on entend certains
personnages soignants mais je pense que
c'est plus un problème de système et
d'organisation que de moyens si je ne me
trompe pas le si on rapporte le coup de
la santé quotidienne des Français ça
représente plus de 12% du PIB donc même
si ce ne sont des chiffres ça vaut quand
même dire qu'on met des moyens et c'est
vrai qu'on a un système de santé qui est
certes très critiqué parfois de
l'intérieur mais on peut s'enorgueillir
quand on compare à d'autres pays qu'il
est ouvert à tous et qu'on soit
globalement tout le monde des plus
démunis au plus riche de la même façon
donc ça c'est quand même important de le
rappeler et je pense qu'on a mis
beaucoup de pansements sur quelqu'un qui
était malade c'est-à-dire l'hôpital et
je m'exprime aussi en tant que président
du sens hospitalier du comité des élus
du groupe hospital Daniel qui représente
9 hôpitaux avec les équipements
adjacents aujourd'hui leur est à mettre
une bonne prothèse si je peux faire
cette comparaison médicale et plus et
sortons des pansements donc je pense que
la nouvelle impulsion que veut porter le
président de la République sans doute
été un peu aussi empêché en fin de
quinqu précédent notamment par rapport à
une crise sans précédent qu'on a du tout
gérer particulièrement les soignants
d'ailleurs parce qu'on peut les
remercier à nouveau me semble aller dans
le bon sens une nouvelle impulsion je me
rappelle François Brown qui est aussi je
crois pour la première fois ministre de
la prévention et de la santé c'est
important qu'on parle de prévention
parce que on diminue les besoins après
en traitement de santé mais donc avait
dit qu'il pouvait remettre à plat moi je
pense qu'il faudrait même aller jusqu'à
une remise à place qu'on en a les moyens
aujourd'hui je ne le sais pas mais je
pense qu'il y a vraiment un temps
médical à retrouver et donc une nouvelle
organisation peut être à laisser un peu
plus d'autonomie dans les différents
pôles à retrouver une nouvelle
gouvernance aussi qui est proposée par
le Président de la République et je
pense que c'est c'est cela qu'il faut
voir notamment de la gouvernance ce
binôme se tandem médecin administratif à
la tête des établissements hospitaliers
bouliers intervenir au Liberté peut-être
sur le la question que je posais
pourquoi le Ségur a pas a pas suffi je
voulais revenir sur cette question de on
a beaucoup investi on a mis beaucoup
d'argent dans le système de la pourquoi
ça va pas suffi parce que en fait il y
avait des années qu'on le sait les
problèmes ne sont pas que financiers à
l'hôpital aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs on
parle toujours de l'hôpital et c'est
aussi ce qu'on est en train de faire
mais 90% des médecins sont formés à
l'hôpital alors que l'essentiel du
système de santé ne repose pas que sur
le pittage aussi sur la médecine
libérale et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on a
une véritable problématique d'accès aux
soins parce qu'on a plus de médecine
libérale on a des déserts médicaux parce
qu'on a plus de médecine libérale et on
ne peut pas avoir de médecine libérale
si on ne forme pas les gens en soins
ambulatoire si on les maintient dans les
hôpitaux et on maintient les gens dans
les hôpitaux parce qu'ils ne sont plus
attractifs parce que certes on rémunéré
mal les gens mais aller dans un hôpital
aller dans une chambre de garde regarder
les rats la parcourir et priez moi de
vous croire que vous allez en partir dès
que vous le pourrez
et donc les gens ne restent pas à
l'hôpital ils ne vont plus non plus en
médecine libérale en fait maintenant on
a des médecins qui partent à l'étranger
on a des médecins qui arrêtent d'exercer
parce que on préfère se réorienter on
préfère exercer moins plutôt que
d'exercer de la médecine alors vous avez
évoqué cette on en a parlé à cette perte
alors nous on a fait un choix
c'est-à-dire que on va être plutôt
centré sur l'hôpital on fera on refera
un débat sur la médecine de ville
évidemment il y a énormément de choses à
dire sur la médecine de ville mais là en
45 minutes on peut pas être on peut pas
vraiment réformer le système de santé en
45 minutes on est ambitieux mais pas
voilà bref je voudrais revenir sur cette
question des conditions de travail de
des soignants qui qui nous disent de
venir maltraitant enfin ce terme est
quand même
violent maltraitant faute de temps la
semaine dernière plus de 90% des
soignants des urgences de Pontois se
sont mis en arrêt maladie justement pour
dénoncer le manque de moyens comme
Deborah bokachar qui est infirmière aux
urgences elle explique justement
pourquoi elle s'est placée en arrêt
maladie ce jour-là
parce que quand je rentre chez moi
j'arrive pas à dormir parce que je
retrouve des patients 48 heures après
les avoir inscrits aux urgences des
patients de 95 ans qui pourraient être
ma famille et que quand je dis un
patient que je reviens je reviens jamais
[Musique]
que j'ai 40 patients à moi toute seule
et qu'on veut pas surveiller tout le
monde et que le jour où c'est mon
diplôme qui va sauter parce qu'on va
retrouver quelqu'un de mort il y a
personne qui va venir avec moi au
tribunal et surtout pas la direction
donc aujourd'hui c'est plus possible
donc aujourd'hui on s'est tous mis en
arrêt parce qu'on est tous dans la même
situation
Frédéric valve tout des témoignages
comme celui-là vous n'êtes plus
président de la Fédération hospitalière
de France mais vous avez dû en voir
remonter depuis on voit la situation se
dégrader dans les services hospitaliers
qui est principalement dû effectivement
à un manque de personnel à des tensions
sur les effectifs à la nécessité en
permanence de bousculer les plannings et
donc effectivement la fatigue s'accumule
enfin ça commence avant la crise covid
rappelez-vous les les pétitions des
mouvements de grogne des démissions en
masse de certains médecins hospitaliers
ça a démarré avant la crise covid la
crise des urgences on l'a connu dans les
années 2015-2016 aussi bon donc il y a
ça monte ça monte ça monte depuis à la
fin des années 2000 alors pourquoi il y
a pas eu cette grande réforme finalement
que tout le monde appelle de ses vœux
autour de cette table
donc notamment pendant le mandat de de
François Hollande on va pas se lancer
dans
manque de courage politique c'est à dire
que on voit on voit la démographie
médicale pic et du nez c'est à dire
aussi bien en médecine de ville qu'en
médecine hospitalière on voit les
tensions on voit la bureaucratie montée
on voit les problèmes de financement
tendre la situation de plus en plus
importante voilà donc on va pas se
renvoyer la balle les uns les autres
mais globalement depuis le milieu des
années 2000 donc c'est un gouvernement
on va dire de droite jusqu'à la fin des
années 2010 c'était au milieu des années
2010 et un gouvernement de gauche il y a
eu la même politique qui a été faite
globalement rationnement budgétaire très
fort sur l'hôpital parce qu'il fallait
faire des économies et et aujourd'hui on
en paye le prix dont un mot là-dessus
jamais c'est quoi c'est le logiciel on
va dire presque libéral quoi c'est un
hôpital ça gère pas comme une entreprise
donc aujourd'hui on est nombreux vous
êtes nombreux à dire mais on entendait
plus trop ce discours ou il ne il était
inaudible pendant plusieurs on a
contraint la dépense depuis 2010 en tout
cas depuis que l'on dame est devenu
effectivement on parle que de quoi
l'objectif des dépenses d'assurance
maladie qui va être chaque année par le
Parlement chaque année on a voté des
taux de progression qui était
insuffisants et donc on a mis une
pression financière sur l'hôpital
permanente on n'a pas investi si vous
achetez une maison monsieur et que année
après année vous n'entretenez rien du
tout
cinq ans ça va au bout de 10 ans le
carrelage est cassé les fenêtres sont
explosées et votre maison elle part en
morceaux c'est ce qu'on a fait avec
l'hôpital pourquoi par la contrainte
budgétaire donc d'abord un il y a une
question de moyens et quand cette année
on a voté un budget des hôpitaux en
hausse de 4%, le chef de l'État dit on
frappa plus parce que c'est historique
mais l'inflation elle est à 6 ce qui est
historique c'est de voter un budget de
l'hôpital 2% en dessous du taux de
l'inflation c'était jamais arrivé et
deuxièmement et je vais vous expliquer
cette infir parce qu'il lui arrive c'est
que du coup qu'est-ce qu'on a demandé
aux hôpitaux quand une infirmière il y a
15 ou 20 ans avait 8 ou 10 passants dont
elle veut s'occuper Frédéric valtoul le
sait on est passé à 12 elle référentiel
c'est 15 maintenant on lui demande 15
patients toute la journée qu'elle en a
40 ans et en plus monsieur virage
ambulatoire donc les patients les plus
légers sortis de l'hôpital l'infirmière
elle ne peut
plus dans 10 jours au Sénat nous allons
débattre d'une loi que j'ai déposée et
qui fils vise à fixer un nombre minimum
de soignants par patient cette semaine
ont lieu les auditions j'en sors encore
il faut écouter les organisations
soignantes des médecins au kiné en
passant par les infirmières tous
réclament qu'on Institute des ratios
minimum des soignants moi je suis 100%
d'accord avec vous mais est-ce que
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir les recruter il
faudra du temps on va pas tout faire du
jour au lendemain mais on a bien perdu 6
ans ou 50 ma santé 2022 dernier discours
du chef de l'État si on commence et
d'état de pays l'ont fait vous avez 300
études internationales sur cette
question la Californie l'a fait
l'Australie etc l'Irlande est en train
de le faire évidemment qu'il faudra
plusieurs années mais aujourd'hui si
vous dites à une infirmière que rien ne
va changer elle va continuer à partir si
vous lui dites certes vous avez 15
passions aujourd'hui mais l'année
prochaine vous en aurez plus que 13 et
dans 5 ans on arrivera à 12 etc vous lui
donnez un cap et vous lui donnez de
l'esprit il me semble qu'il y a un
phénomène aussi qui peut expliquer qu'on
mette pas le paquet sur l'hôpital c'est
que l'hôpital on s'en occupe quand on
est malade ou qu'on a des proches
malades ou qu'on est mourant mais le
reste du temps n'a pas trop envie de
s'en occuper on n'a pas forcément envie
de manifester on voit pas forcément du
soutien par contre depuis la crise covid
alors comme par hasard c'est devenu la
préoccupation l'une des premières
préoccupations des Français on a
applaudi vous vous souvenez évidemment
les soignants à 20h mais après il y a
plus tellement de manifestations de
soutien parce que c'est pas quelque
chose auquel on veut penser habitué
c'est intéressant c'est sur le plan
politique c'est horriblement cynique ce
que je vais vous dire mais ça paye moins
parce que par exemple soutenir
l'économie pendant la crise covid ça a
été flagrant on a lancé un plan de
relance 100 milliards d'euros là on
parle de 19 milliards d'euros mais c'est
sur 10 ans quand même l'hôpital donc on
n'est pas du tout dans les mêmes
échelles parce que ça n'a pas le même
poids politique auprès de la des
citoyens y compris dans le monde
politique
aujourd'hui c'est quand même parmi les
premières préoccupations des Français
c'est la question c'est pas tellement
l'avenir de l'hôpital tout seul c'est la
question de l'accès aux soins tout le
monde voit le système se déliter et moi
je peux vous dire je j'ai été maire
jusqu'à l'été dernier mais je suis
encore toutes les toutes les semaines
comme tous les élus avec les gens les
gens ne parlent beaucoup plus de ça et
je vais vous dire même très concrètement
dans les cérémonies de vie aujourd'hui
on parle plus de problèmes de l'accès
aux soins que le problème de la réforme
des retraites parce que c'est une
angoisse réelle les gens les médecins en
grève ils travaillent ils ont juste le
brassard les médecins hospitalier
parce que les cabinets de ville ils ont
fermé en grève donc on sent pas
tellement et
travaillent alors je reviens aux
conditions de travail et ça rejoint la
question de la capacité de recruter du
personnel médical ou paramédical et on
va écouter un extrait de du discours de
d'Emmanuel Macron donc le 6 janvier
dernier il annonce des recrutements
d'assistant médicaux
nous allons à cet égard accélérer le
recrutement des assistants médicaux pour
les médecins
on a aujourd'hui près de 4000 assistants
médicaux qui ont déjà signé un contrat
et ce qui est un des vrais succès on
doit arriver à 10000 d'ici la fin de
l'année prochaine et ça c'est faisable
et donc je souhaite qu'on les généralise
on va continuer et donc on va accroître
les financements pour le faire inciter
davantage et ça permet de délester des
tâches périphériques aux soins et ce que
je veux c'est qu'on puisse aussi
l'appliquer à l'hôpital où nous
basculerons des personnels
administratifs logistiques techniques au
plus près des services pour permettre
aux soignants de se concentrer sur le
cœur de leur métier alors ça concerne
d'abord la médecine de ville on est bien
d'accord mais vous entendez Emmanuel
Macron dit on veut appliquer la même
logique à l'hôpital oui mais ça concerne
à l'hôpital il y a un ensemble de
métiers qui normalement répondent à la
problématique qui est par contre et
celle des médecins de vie il y a des
secrétaires etc etc bon donc en tout cas
ce projet est un bon projet il existe
d'ailleurs depuis des années il est
déployé beaucoup trop lentement et
encore une fois c'est la question de la
priorité et c'est là la question
budgétaire tout de même j'ai entendu que
et le maire de Nevers nous dire mais
nous nous dépensons beaucoup pour la
santé c'est vrai mais encore on regarde
l'évolution des dépenses de santé sur 20
ou 30 ans donc je sors de la polémique
entre la droite et la gauche et les uns
et les autres quand vous regardez sur
cette durée là certes on a consacré 8%
de plus on s'appuie pour cent de plus à
la santé 1 on ne recouvrant pas plus
mais les plus de 60 ans c'est plus 30 %
et les plus de 60 ans c'est eux qui
génèrent la grande majorité des dépenses
de santé en fait on a sous investi dans
la santé on a l'impression qu'on a
dépensé beaucoup parce que c'est des
sommes assez considérables mais année
après année on a sous investi et quand
année après année il manque trois ou
quatre milliards à l'hôpital certes il
manque que trois ou quatre milliards une
année se débrouillent mais je reprends
l'exemple d'une maison que vous achetez
et dans laquelle vous n'investissez pas
assez elle se dégrade et nous en sommes
arrivés au stade où l'hôpital est
dégradé et où le système ambulatoire
pour des raisons un peu différentes le
numerus clausus etc mais malgré tout
c'est aussi dégradé les Français
atterrés qui avaient dans la tête l'idée
qu'on avait le meilleur problème de
santé au monde réalise que ce système
sur ces deux principaux pieds est en
train de s'affaisser je ne dis pas
effondré j'espère qu'il ne va pas
s'effondrer ça tient quand même sur
beaucoup de choses mais il est en train
de s'affaisser la situation est grave il
y a une question de moyens après vous
avez raison il y a des questions de
gouvernance d'organisation de partager
des tâches de tas de choses dont on
discute au Parlement on discute les
acteurs qu'Emmanuel Macron a porté et
qu'il faut effectivement changer mais il
y a un cadre général qui est
problématique et qui n'est pas que celui
de alors je vais vous donner la parole
sur ce plateau mais je voudrais revenir
vers le maire de Nevers Denis thuriaux
peut-être sur on est en train de se
poser la question de l'attractivité des
métiers de de santé et des moyens pour
faire finalement gagner du temps médical
aux soignants est-ce que vous pensez que
il faut simplifier leur tâche c'est ce
qu'il y a trop de de tâches
administratives demandées aux soignants
en général
oui ça c'est évident et c'est une
maladie assez française on la retrouve
dans beaucoup de domaines et je pense
que la recherche de la simplification
parfois même des mêmes au contrat des
augmentations de tâches donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut
arriver à réaliser ça te passera sans
doute et j'ai bien entendu qu'on en
reparlerai sur la gouvernance des
hôpitaux mais surtout décharger les
soignants de tâches qui prennent une
bonne partie de leur temps moi quand je
les entends je les comprends aussi je
suis professionnel également donc je
peux comprendre cela et donc cela me ça
me semblait dans le bon sens d'augmenter
les assistants médicaux faut que ça soit
la discrétion du médecin je comprends
que les médecins qui estiment parfois
devoir se débrouiller sans mais
l'augmentation de 6000 sera pas anodine
je l'espère sur le temps qui du coup
sera dégagé pour donner un peu plus de
de solutions d'intervention médicale et
donc cela est une est une première chose
après il y a aussi peut-être la façon de
partager les tâches je sais que tous les
médecins ne sont pas d'accord mais il y
a peut-être et si on parle de médecine
de ville on peut quand même aborder le
sujet il y a des tâches qui peuvent être
donnés parfois des pharmaciens sur des
petites pathologies je pense aussi à la
télémédecine qui n'est pas la panacée
qui m'a remplacera jamais le médecin
mais qui peut par exemple dermatologie
peut permettre un prédiagnostic je pense
aussi peut-être à des relances de SOS
Médecins parce qu'il y a aussi les
urgences à décharger ou parler du Ségur
tout à l'heure lanière en bénéficier
notamment avec la nouvelle hôpital à
cause sur Loire par contre moi je n'ai
pas eu les moyens pour l'instant mais
j'ai un échange de Mac le ministère de
refaire les urgences à Nevers qui sont
sous-dimensionnés qui ont qui ont deux
fois plus de passage que ça ne devrait
être et parfois des passages d'ailleurs
qui ne sont pas justifiés donc il faut
trouver une solution aussi pour
décharger certains services qui sont
saturés je crois savoir plus urgences
c'est à peu près partout donc hier je
pense des efforts qui peuvent parfois
être assez simples dans une nouvelle
organisation en mettant des personnels
consacrés à l'administration ou aux
tâches plus techniques Olivia frignau
autour d'expérience pour gagner ce temps
médical parce que finalement on a parlé
de ses soignants qui se qui se vivent
maltraitants quoi quotidiennement c'est
peut-être aussi le cas de beaucoup
d'internes que vous représentez
que vous imaginez qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour gagner du temps
médical
et je pense que il y a plusieurs choses
il y a deux aspects majeurs le premier
ça va être d'investir massivement dans
la formation tant sur le nombre de
personnels conformes parce qu'en fait en
formant toujours moins de personnes on a
à la fois moins de gens qui restent
après et à la fois moins de gens pour
vous aider au cours de votre formation
nous par exemple quand on est interne on
est devrait professionnel de santé on
est médecin à part entière à l'hôpital
on présente même 40% des médecins des
hôpitaux publics donc vraiment des
médecins de l'hôpital public quand on
est de moins en moins nombreux forcément
il y a de moins en moins de monde pour
faire les soins et donc de plus en plus
de lourdeur de travail et charges une
pression qui deviennent presque
inhumaine en fait et parce que vous êtes
moins c'est aussi moins attractif
ensuite et investir dans la formation et
investir dans ce qui va faire que les
gens vont rester pour que les conditions
de travail se restent bonnes ce père
enfin elle est bonne condition de
travail se pérennise et ainsi réussir à
dégager du temps médical parce que on
aura plus de soignants aujourd'hui en
fait on fait de la délégation de tâches
inversée à l'hôpital ce sont les
externes qui font les tâches des
aides-soignants et des et des infirmiers
ce sont interne qui font les tâches des
externes ce sont les chefs de services
qui font les tâches des internes parce
que on a plus personne qui reste en bas
de en bas de en bas de l'échelle enfin
vous me pardonnerez l'expérience
et sur l'aspect administratif est-ce que
à votre niveau je sais pas sur une
journée de travail il y a XR passer à ne
pas faire de santé quoi vous voyez ce
que je veux dire qu'on a pu réaliser
auprès de nos internes ils estiment
entre 20 et 40% de leur temps de
présence à l'hôpital qui rappelons-le et
de l'ordre de 60 heures par semaine en
moyenne
qui est dédié uniquement à des tâches
administratifs qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la prise en charge médicale donc on
ne compte pas là dedans la rédaction des
comptes rendus d'hospitalisation par
exemple parce qu'on a décidé d'être
sympa mais encore qu'on pourrait se dire
qu'il existe des façons de rendre ça
plus fluide et moins chronophage aussi
mais donc 20 à 40% de 60 heures par
semaine ce qui est un autre sujet
qui ne sont que du temps administratif
du temps pendant lesquels des gens qui
sont bac + 10 11 12 ne font pas de
médecine mais des tâches administratives
alors vous avez évoqué la question de de
la formation et du recrutement ça pose
évidemment le thème du numerus clausus
et je me tourne vers Quentin Calmet qui
était là juste derrière le rideau en
coulisses rebond soit attentivement
Emmanuel Macron qui se targue d'avoir
évidemment réalisé une réforme
importante en la matière puisqu'il a
supprimé ce numéro muscleusus le numerus
clausus qui est la limitation du nombre
de médecins formés chaque année en
France il a été supprimé en 2019 le
nombre d'étudiants admis à entrer en
formation était jusque-là fixée par
décret ministériel Emmanuel Macron qui
dès la campagne de 2017 avait parlé du
numérique clausus comme du numerus
clausus comme inefficace et injuste mais
alors il date de quand ce numérus
clausus je vous conseille un article de
publicsana.fr écrit par mon collègue
Louis Mollier Sabet on y comprend que le
nuage clausus a été créé au début des
années 70 il est institué à la demande
des syndicats de médecins libéraux
historiquement très bien organisé depuis
le début du 20e siècle qu'il s'agit pour
eux de répondre aux événements de Mai 68
et des désordres dans les amphis des
facultés de médecine et aussi de
répondre à la forte augmentation du
nombre d'étudiants de médecine plus 69%
entre 1963 et 1967 la profession c'est
un si organisé pour garantir aussi des
revenus au médecin en tentant de limiter
en mathématiquement leur nombre et le
gouvernement de l'époque mais les
gouvernements suivants et bien ils ont
réduit petit à petit le numerus clausus
car ils ont vu un moyen de réduire les
dépenses de santé et c'est le cas depuis
les années 70 je voulais vous montrer un
graphique Thomas puisque on voit
l'évolution du numérique cosus depuis
1971 pendant les premiers années avec sa
mise en place jusqu'en 1977 ce sont 8500
places par an environ qui était offerte
pour l'entrée dans les études de
médecine ensuite ce chiffre a fortement
diminué jusqu'en 93 où il a été il a
atteint son minimum de 3 500 places
offertes par an il a ensuite été
fortement rehaussée dans le but de
remplacer les départs à la retraite des
médecins issus du baby-boom la hausse
très forte entre 2000-2005 c'est ralenti
jusqu'au milieu des années 2010 mais
pour repartir ensuite et atteint donc un
peu plus de 9300 places c'était en 2020
lorsqu'il a été supprimé et la fin de ce
numéro explosus ne signifie pas la fin
de la pénurie immédiate de mes deux
médecins évidemment voilà et on en
revient à un rapport du Sénat de 2022
écrit par Catherine Deroche un président
de la commission frères social à l'écrit
les effets de la suppression du numerus
clausus ne se feront sentir au mieux
qu'à partir du début de la décennie 2030
sans garantie de répartition équitable
sur le territoire envoyé cette citation
du rapport la cause est bien les
capacités d'accueil et des moyens de
formation des étudiants sont contraints
et ils ne vont progresser que trop
lentement ainsi le nombre de médecins en
France va continuer de diminuer entre
2021 et 2026 passant de 95
000 à 12000 et c'est après 2030 Thomas
qu'il devrait commencer à augmenter de
nouveau merci Quentin pour tous ces
détails historiques et c'est et ces
chiffres Frédéric Valtou pourquoi il a
fallu attendre aussi longtemps pour
abandonner le système on revient un peu
sur la conversation qu'on avait tout à
l'heure quoi on était chez employé le
terme intoxiqué à une logique quoi
comptable oui bah il y a la conjonction
de différentes choses il y a le jeu des
syndicats de médecins il y a la croyance
sans doute d'une autre administration
qu'on va réguler et contenir les
dépenses de santé en régulant le nombre
d'éandix en contenant le nombre de de
médecins formés enfin voilà il y a sans
doute les habitudes il y a le
conformisme du système il y a
différentes effectivement
cause qui explique cela
ça n'est que récemment que on réouvre
les vannes et à la fois budgétaires et
effectivement sur la sur la formation il
y avait aussi les universités qui
étaient calibrés pour un certain format
d'étudiants et qui trouvaient
confortable de pas tellement se poser
plus de questions donc c'est une
question est-ce qu'on a les moyens d'en
former beaucoup plus
calibrer les murs et que il va falloir
pousser les murs il va falloir de toute
façon on sait que dans les années qui
viennent aussi bien pour les métiers
médicaux que paramédicaux il y a des
besoins qui sont énormes et donc il va
falloir effectivement qu'on a juste
les les à la fois les locaux mais aussi
peut-être des programmes de formation à
ses besoins à ses besoins nouveaux
le système est à la veille d'un grand
chamboule tout et moi je le souhaite en
tous les cas parce que on peut plus
continuer avec des habitudes du passé on
parlait rapidement de liturios parlait
des délégations tâches et majeures
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement mais on
voit la résistance encore de certains
médecins libéraux notamment qui sont
mènent une petite guerre là parce que
arrivent à l'Assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi qui organise
justement ces délégations tâches autour
notamment des infirmières de pratiques
avancées et du rôle qu'elle pourrait
avoir donc ce sont des infirmières qui
ont une formation supplémentaire de deux
années
qui effectivement dans le cadre d'un
contrôle médical mais peuvent prendre en
charge directement et avec aussi la
possibilité d'ouvrir une prescription
autorisée primo prescription comment une
première prescription pour ses pour ses
professionnels pour décharger là aussi
et décharger enfin redonner au médecin
du temps du temps médical vous avez tout
à l'heure je veux dire d'un mot mais
vous pouviez pas montrer tous l'extrait
du discours de d'Emmanuel Macron mais
dans ce qu'il annonce vis-à-vis du monde
libéral et notamment c'est c'est ces
assistants médicaux 6000 assistants
médicaux supplémentaires qui vont faire
les tâches administratives à la place
des des médecins comme on le disait il y
a aussi une contrepartie qui est de dire
il va falloir revoir les comme on disait
une époque les droits et les devoirs
c'est-à-dire la contrepartie de ça de
l'effort de la Nation pour sous vous
soulager en matière administrative pour
vous donner des moyens de de faire plus
de médecine et bien c'est que vous
intégriez aussi dans vos pratiques les
objectifs d'intérêt général que l'on
parle là de la permanence des soins
c'est-à-dire la garde et effectivement
une prise en charge peut-être plus plus
plus plus affirmée dans les territoires
donc voilà il y a un grand une grande
réorganisation du système de santé mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas le
choix vous savez c'est comme cette
personne qui arrive au fond de la
piscine si on donne pas un coup de pied
on ne prend pas ça c'est sûr la
délégation et la délégation de certains
actes de de santé j'entendais en venant
à Public Sénat à la radio chez nos
confrères de France Info en l'occurrence
des des représentants de de médecins
syndicat de médecins qui qui disait mais
non on y est résolument au style et vous
qui représentez les internes
un communiqué de presse qui affirmait
que on était en faveur des transferts de
compétences à condition de certains
principes fondamentaux et simples qu'il
ne s'associent pas à une baisse de la
qualité des soins pour la population
parce que encore une fois je pense que
le principe fondamental ça doit être le
patient que les que la formation soit
anticipée c'est-à-dire dans son
financement mais aussi dans sa maquette
et que cette maquette de formation pour
les nouveaux professionnels qui vont
recevoir cette nouvelle compétence soit
co-construite entre ceux qui ont la
compétence aujourd'hui par exemple les
médecins et ceux qui vont la recevoir
demain par exemple les infirmiers pour
que parce qu'aujourd'hui si vous avez
une seule personne qui détient la
compétence il est aussi a priori la
seule à savoir comment on l'obtient
comment on l'entretient etc et
d'ailleurs je parlais de formation mais
la formation initiale et la formation
continue parce que les métiers de santé
à titre d'informations tous les tous les
7 ans plus de 50% des données de santé
enfin son cas duc donc la formation
continue en santé c'est quelque chose de
primordial qui doit être anticipé
budgétisé
vous vouliez intervenir je vous voyais
sur mon écran de contrôle
de la République alors qui était
candidat assez en 2017 qu'il a annoncé à
Nevers la fin du numerus donc j'en étais
ravi et j'en avais parlé avec lui donc
je pense que ça prend du temps c'est une
mesure qu'on aurait dû décider
auparavant c'est comme ça ils veulent
tout parler de courage politique il n'a
pas été exercé avant Emmanuel Macron au
moins elle a affirmé mais on sait que ça
prend du temps il y a plusieurs
possibilités pour retenir jusque là sur
cette petite décennie ou en tout cas
cette huit ans qu'il reste pour qu'enfin
on a une augmentation du nombre de
médecins il y a d'abord des médecins qui
sont en forme à l'heure où on parle
d'ailleurs de la réforme des retraites
pour envisager l'avenir certains
médecins qui me disent ben moi je suis
prêt à continuer si on nous facilite
l'exercice une fois ma retraite prise
puisqu'on peut continuer l'activité mais
peut-être alléger encore notamment
l'aspect administratif et financier donc
on pourrait avoir un certain nombre de
médecins volontaires qui si je puis dire
remplirait prolonger de leur plein gré
bien évidemment après moi je plaide
aussi pour peut-être de davantage de
validation des acquis et je prends
l'exemple des infirmières de bolloc je
un sujet qui est une mise en place de
formation d'infirmières de blog dans les
territoires on a mis 30 ans pour obtenir
le passe santé cette première année de
médecine qui s'appelait comme cela avant
on peut l'exercice aussi à distance si
on a de bons résultats au moins autant
que c'est que à l'université Dijon donc
je pense que beaucoup de villes comme
Nevers pour accueillir ce passe santé ce
qui permettrait aussi de créer des
vocations parce que certains étudiants
potentiels s'interdisent parce qu'on
sait que c'est une première année qui
est compliquée et je pense aussi pour
prendre l'exemple l'autre jour j'ai
assisté l'intervention et une infirmière
me disait je veux devenir infirmière de
blocs mais j'ai aujourd'hui j'ai des
petits enfants je parle faire ces
déplacements dans des vues
universitaires donc je quitte Nevers et
toute ma famille et ça il faut vraiment
s'orienter sur des formations de
proximité aujourd'hui c'est possible y
compris avec les nouvelles technologies
y compris à distance et il y a également
une pénurie on le sait d'infirmière de
blog d’infirmation
qui empêche nos plateaux techniques
davantage utilisé et donc ça enlève des
recettes pour des hôpitaux pardon de
couper la parole je voudrais
les plus rentables au détriment des
actes qui sont plus coûteux et plus
longs Emmanuel Macron et on l'a dit tout
à l'heure avait proposé de plafonner
cette tarification en 2018 ça n'a pas
été fait c'est vrai que le personnel est
un peu déçu par le Ségur de la santé et
par ses annonces il préférerait
peut-être des actes aux paroles et c'est
un petit peu ce qu'ils attendent à
l'heure actuelle est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres mesures dans ce plan pour le
service public de la santé
est toujours pas très très loin puisque
dans le dans le le côté médecine libéral
Emmanuel Macron propose sur la
permanence des soins une espèce de
donnant-donnant c'est à dire vous avez
un petit peu plus d'argent si vous
investissez plus sur la performance sur
la permanence des soins et ça rappelle
un petit peu ce qu'il avait fait dans un
autre service public qui est l'école en
disant les professeurs on peut les
rémunérer davantage s'ils s'investissent
plus sur l'activité périscolaire les
projets pédagogiques donc on va les mais
c'est leur temps c'est pas c'est pas des
augmentations c'est leur temps de
travail et ça rappelle aussi
le côté école ce qui avait été lancé je
pense que vous en souvenez les
recrutements en 30 minutes ce qui a fait
pas mal de dégâts parce que ça a permis
de répondre à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre avec des recrutement très
rapides mais avec aussi beaucoup de
démission à la suite parce que ça
s'invente pas d'être professeur et
surtout en 30 minutes c'est difficile de
savoir si on va être un bon professeur
ou pas et ça rappelle aussi ce qui a été
voté alors on parlait de formation c'est
intéressant et de formation continue
parce que également sur ce service
public il y a eu des changements il y a
un compte personnel de formation qu'on a
chacun pour entamer des formations et
qui est gratuit en quelque sorte sauf
que ça coûte de plus en plus cher à
l'organisme qui gère ça qui s'appelle
France compétences et du coup on a
décidé ça vient d'être voté on va voir
si c'est confirmé qu'une partie des
formations va être directement payée par
les salariés eux-mêmes donc quand on
sait que les formations c'est souvent
ceux qui en ont le moins besoin et au
contraire les plus modestes et qui en
aurait le plus besoin ont du mal à aller
se former parce que c'est difficile en
terme de temps de travail ou quoi c'est
encore plus compliqué si on leur demande
de donner une part pour se former
eux-mêmes donc on voit bien que il y a
une espèce de voilà de de va-et-vient
entre une vision très comptable des
services publics et puis l'idée d'avoir
un service public à la hauteur
finalement on se dit qu'une ambition des
paroles et des mesures un peu gadgets ça
fait pas une politique de service public
et que c'est plutôt une question de
choix et vous l'avez dit de dépenser
d'allocation des dépenses c'est-à-dire
où est-ce que dans quel domaine et à
quelle hauteur le service public doit
perdurer dans quel état s'investit et
peut-être d'autres endroits où il peut
déléguer certaines tâches ou se retirer
progressivement c'est une question de
poids très importante et de société mais
à l'heure de la réforme des retraites et
avec la mobilisation sociale qui
s'annonce c'est pas forcément le
meilleur moment pour attaquer ce sujet
assez long on verra ça est-ce qu'il a
changé de pied Frédéric Valtou
globalement au-delà de des services de
santé sur des services publics sur sa
vision des services sur les services
publics en général
ou sur le service public de santé
si vous voulez parce que sinon ça va
nous amener
une minute voilà en une minute moi je
pense pas parce qu'on évoquait le le
discours de septembre 2018 et qui ont on
retrouve des accents dans celui de la
semaine dernière ce qui veut bien dire
que voilà 2018 on était à 18 mois de sa
première élection donc on y a des
permanences après il y a effectivement
la nécessité de ne pas faire que des
discours mais au contraire d'être très
vigilant la mise en oeuvre et c'est ce
qu'on va tester dans les prochains mois
il y avait pas enfin la crise covid ça a
forcément tout gelé mais c'est forcément
tout gelé parce qu'on peut pas toucher
aux organisations hospitalières au rôle
des uns des autres etc alors que les
soignants étaient le nez au front et que
on savait pas très bien où on allait en
plus même si progressivement on a vu la
vague sur tirée les vagues mais
globalement on aurait pas compris et
puis le Parlement travaillait pas enfin
travaillez-moi en tout cas donc on
n'aurait pas compris qu'on lance de
grandes réformes sur un service public
qui était en première ligne et qui avait
déjà pas non pas du mal parce que ça
tenu enfin à quel prix aussi donc on
termine là-dessus il fallait plutôt
aider les soignants dans cette période
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat ici en plateau et
duplex à bientôt sur Public Sénat voilà
c'est la fin de ce numéro à demain
18h22 heures et votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
dans la matinale Oriane mansini reçoit
Patrick canner le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat belle soirée
[Musique]